hey this is sort of funny Joe Biden is
hilariously claiming to be the most
progressive candidate running in the
2020 Democratic primary which is
obviously not true
now Biden actually said this a couple of
weeks ago before he even announced he
was running and in the clip I'm gonna
play for you you'll notice that Biden's
sort of slips and says he's the most
progressive candidate running even
though at the time he wasn't running and
it was sort of a signal that pretty
clearly he's going to be but the point
of all this is Joe Biden claiming to be
the most progressive candidate take a
look at this I know I get criticized I'm
told on you criticized by the new left I
the most progressive record of anybody
running for the universe anybody who
would run so this is simply not true
like that there are many things that we
can say about Biden that are true and I
told you some of them and they're not
all things I'm thrilled with and they're
not all things our audience is thrilled
with so Joe Biden's polling really well
okay
there are a number of new polls that
came out over the weekend one from
Harvard Harris has Biden polling at 44%
okay even if off by several points
that's huge
the latest CNN poll has Biden polling
39% the latest Quinnipiac poll has Biden
polling 38% I know that there are people
who will take issue with individual
polls but these are good numbers and you
can take issue with liking Biden you can
say Biden is not a progressive which I
say but it's a true statement that Biden
is polling really well you can
accurately say Biden's raising a ton of
money okay he set a record for the first
24 hours among other 20/20 candidates
did Joe Biden's money come from larger
donations from a smaller pool of donors
absolutely as I told you about last week
but it's true that Joe Biden raised more
money in his first day than any other of
the 2020 Democratic candidates but
there's no factual case to be made that
Joe Biden's the most progressive
candidate here is Bernie Sanders when
asked about this over the weekend saying
yeah that's not the case I'm sure you
saw Joe Biden say that he is the most
progressive candidate in this race well
look good Joe is a good friend of mine
and I'm not here to attack Joe
Joe voted for the war in Iraq I led the
effort against it Joe voted for NAFTA
and permanent normal trade relations
trade agreements with China I have led
the effort against that Joe voted for
the deregulation of wall street I voted
against that you know I think if you
look at Joe's record and you look at my
record I don't think there's much
question about who's more progressive
Joe Biden is not the most progressive
candidate obviously and that should be
made crystal clear what's problematic is
that there are some on the Left saying
Biden is just like Trump and you've got
to just stop being stupid okay that's
exactly the type of attack that hurts us
in the general election Biden's not
Trump okay Biden's basically Hillary and
as we know right now Hillary was not
Trump the Supreme Court would look very
different if Hillary Clinton was
president our relationships with many of
our historical allies would look very
different if Hillary Clinton was
president so there are memes floating
around there's one that has you know 20
different parameters and the case it
makes is that unlike all but one of them
Trump and Biden are the same the
difference between them being Biden's
polite whereas Donald Trump is crass
that's destructive as much as it is
silly and stupid okay there's one
positive thing here I do want to point
out in a way sort of good that Joe Biden
feels the need to lie about being the
most progressive what I mean in sort of
other words is Biden is claiming to be
most progressive because he must believe
that it's good for him to people for
people to see him as more progressive
than he actually is
he has assessed that saying I'm a
sensible center-left Democrat that
doesn't seem as appealing in his mind to
the electorate as claiming to be the
most progressive candidate so in a sense
that maybe is an indicator that things
are continuing to move to the left in
terms of the candidates on the
Democratic side it's simply not true
that Biden is the most progressive
Biden's a centrist he is I think what I
would call a sort of status quo down
crowd it's not just about where exactly
on the political spectrum is Biden he's
center-left he's basically Hillary it's
that he is not a progressive candidate
but if he's the nominee I'm gonna vote
for him over Trump I mean this is where
I don't want to see the left evolved
into this Biden is just like Trump stuff
because it's ridiculous and there are
low information voters who will fall for
it
Biden is endlessly better than Trump but
he's not what I would describe as a
progressive Democrat and I don't think
there's any factual case you can make to
support that claim my hope is if Biden
ends up being the nominee and Biden ends
up becoming president of the United
States if Democrats are able to maintain
control of the house in 2020 and 2022
and then are able to take control of the
Senate in 2022 very unlikely that
Democrats would take control in 2020 of
the Senate no matter what happens in the
White House if in 2022 Biden gets the
house and the Senate I hope that we will
have a progressive enough House and
Senate that they will do really
progressive things and Biden will not
get in the way of those things it's sort
of setting the bar relatively low but I
think practically speaking that's kind
of the best-case scenario if Joe Biden
ends up being president today's program
is sponsored in part by our friends over
at Loch Ness crypto dot-com the team is
based in Boise Idaho and they've made it
their mission to help just everyday
people navigate the world of
cryptocurrency and they've been doing it
since 2012 they've actually been
teaching a course about cryptocurrency
at the Boise State computer science
department for years and they've taken
that curriculum and sort of packed it
into an easy to digest course that's now
available to anybody who wants it called
the cryptocurrency starter kit and this
is the type of thing that crypto has
really been lacking and it's one of the
reasons we we maybe haven't seen
adoption of currencies like Bitcoin and
others on a larger scale normal people
who are not tech expert
Earth's need a step-by-step guide that's
easy to understand about how they can
get involved with cryptocurrency in a
way that is sort of safe and manageable
and that's what the cryptocurrency
starter kit provides it's a five-part
video series which includes how to
safely obtain Kryptos where to set up
your accounts how to protect those
accounts from hackers importantly how to
move crypto into physical hardware
wallets and also how to just prepare for
the future of the space you also get a
free physical Hardware wallet it's sort
of like a flash drive where you can
safely store your Bitcoin or other
Kryptos offline and you also get one
hour of one on one phone or Skype
mentoring with one of lochness Kryptos
experts they're the only company in the
crypto space that offers a service like
this and it all comes with the
cryptocurrency starter kit they have a
special offer specifically for the David
Pakman show audience if you click the
link under this video you'll get $200
off the cryptocurrency starter kit check
it out using the link down below